november is already almost here and the
year is nearly over
already
i feel like it just started
what is time fortunately that means
we're that much closer to getting to
play upcoming games so here are the
biggest games coming out this november
ubisoft's annual just dance franchise is
back again with just dance 2022 i can't
say it's going to be any different from
previous installments but if it ain't
broke
don't fix it ubisoft has already
released a tracklist for the game so if
it's a franchise you enjoy you can head
on over to wikipedia to take a look or
just enjoy this fast scrolling of the
track list on screen not only that but
to hype up the launch of the game just
dance's official youtube channel has
been slowly releasing the partial videos
for the songs and dances that will be in
the upcoming game while most of the
tracks so far more contemporary there
are a number of the tunes dating back
from the 90s to the 70s just dance 2022
releases to the nintendo switch
playstation 4 and 5 xbox one series x
slash s and stadia on november 4th
call of duty is back with its latest
annual installment with call of duty
vanguard and while the franchise started
in world war ii it has bounced around
history a lot from past to near future
and future future sledgehammer games is
bringing it back to world war ii using
their previous experience from the 2017
title call of duty now has multiple
developers creating games during off
years with treyarch handling zombies and
a whole bunch of developers working on
the new warzone map including
sledgehammer games bnox high moon
studios and toys for bob
yes toys for bob who made crash 4.
vanguard will bring an all-new
multiplayer mode champion hill to 4 of
its 20 maps this mode is a squad based
death match where squad mates share a
pool of limited lives and are eliminated
once these are gone call of duty
vanguard releases to windows ps4 ps5
xbox one and series x slash s on
november 5th
the long awaited forza horizon 5 is
finally releasing next month this xbox
and pc exclusive is the latest in the
forza series and will take place in
mexico featuring a variety of terrains
and cars developer playground games
intends to take full advantage of the
differing terrains of the country from
the tropical baja california to the lush
jungles of rio balorte the desert cities
and even volcanoes the varied
environments and weather conditions
means there will be a number of rugged
cars you'll be able to take control of
in order to best handle this along with
sports cars for the more traditional
tracks forza horizon 5 includes brand
new modes including horizon arcade a set
of mini multiplayer games like pinata
pop where players work together to pop
various pinatas and event lab a mode
allowing players to create their own
customized races and games forza horizon
5 releases to windows xbox one and xbox
series x s november 9th with early
access on november 5th
shin megami tensei 5. persona 5 is hands
down one of my favorite jrpgs ever i've
been playing jrpgs since their inception
on the nes and p5 rocketed ahead and to
persona fans is a well-known fact that
persona is actually a spin-off of the
megami tensei series which first
released to the famicom in 1987.
confusingly the super famicom's shin
megami tensei one is actually the third
megami tensei game which is what the
series has since been known as and eight
years after shin megami tensei 4 we're
finally getting a full-fledged sequel
for the nintendo switch brief history
lesson aside if you're a jrpg fan this
is definitely something to be excited
for shin megami tensei uses some
traditional turn-based jrpg combat
mechanics with you fighting against
demons and taking control of your
characters similar to persona you'll be
able to combo hits against enemies by
using their weaknesses and properly
strategizing persona players will also
be familiar with another mechanic that
of being able to recruit enemy demons
into your party and fuse them into more
powerful demons shin megami tensei 5
will see you playing as a high school
student exploring rumors about demons
and being drawn into an alternate
apocalyptic version of tokyo shin megami
tensei 5 releases to the nintendo switch
worldwide november 12th
pokemon brilliant diamond and shining
pearl i tend to play pokemon games in
cycles playing every other game in the
series and pokemon diamond and pearl
just happen to be one of those games in
the series that i picked up and fully
played through so i'm excited to see a
remake of the fourth main pokemon entry
coming to the switch with full 3d
graphics especially weasel and floatzel
the greatest gen 4 pokemon around also
lest we forget gen 4 was the home of
many legendary pokemon pokemon like
drifloon who were known for and i quote
from sun and moon stories go that it
grabs the hands of small children and
drags them away to the afterlife it
dislikes heavy children if for some
reason its body burst its soul spills
out with a screaming sound i am never
going to look at balloons the same way
again
brilliant diamond and shining pearl are
mostly faithful remakes of the original
games but with an all-new function for
the poketech allowing you to use hidden
moves with wild pokemon meaning you'll
no longer need to waste the precious
move slot on your pokemon or just carry
around an all-purpose badoof also on a
note that interests me a whole lot this
is actually going to be the very first
pokemon game that won't have game freak
as the lead developer instead ilca will
be the main developer with game freak
overseeing them that said as it's a
remake and not a brand new game and
series veteran and director of the
original game junichi masuda will still
be co-directing this remake i'm sure
there's nothing to worry about pokemon
brilliant diamond and shining pearl
releases to the nintendo switch on
november 19th
battlefield 2042
if battlefield has always been your
go-to fps over call of duty fear not for
this month we'll see a release of both
major fps behemoths whereas call of duty
will be re-exploring the past this year
battlefield 2042 takes place in
just that 2042 mini will be getting
plenty of near futuristic tech to
utilize in its 64 to 128 player online
matches depending on the platform and
speaking of multiplayer this installment
of battlefield is ditching a single
player campaign altogether instead
focusing on story told through
multiplayer gameplay and massive maps in
order to set itself apart from its
predecessors battlefield 2042 will
feature extreme weather such as
tornadoes and sandstorms which will
completely change the way you'll be
forced to adapt and play as well finally
2042 includes a competitive squad based
mode called hazard zone which involves
players roaming around collecting and
extracting data battlefield 2042
releases the windows ps4 ps5 xbox one
and x slash s on november 19th with
early access on ea play
final fantasy xiv and walker final
fantasy 14 was lambasted by many gamers
and press alike when it first released
in 2010 however after going back to the
drawing board and putting in a huge
amount of work a completely recreated
final fantasy 14 version 2.0 a realm
reborn was launched in 2013.
this task wasn't for naught as a realm
reborn completely rewind over players
and became a major money maker for
square while this recreation now
considered the true final fantasy 14 was
originally released in 2013 its
popularity has helped see it through a
series of major expansions including
2015's heaven sword 2017 stormblood and
2019 shadowbringers now around reborn's
fourth expansion and walker is finally
on its way and if you want to know more
about it i highly recommend checking out
our resident final fantasy 14 expert ben
janka's hands-on preview of the
expansion final fantasy 14 end walker
releases to windows mac os ps4 and ps5
on november
23rd and there you have the biggest
games coming out this november
personally i'm looking the most forward
to forza horizon 5 and shin megami
tensei 5 but what are you looking the
most forward to playing let us know in
the comments below and i'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
[Music]